- Sorry, I didn't realize we're live.
Hi everyone, thank you very
much for joining us today
for our session on maxing
AI governance and speed
only with ServiceNow and AWS.
My name is Amanda Grady
and I lead AI platform
security at ServiceNow.
And I'm joined here today by Sampada.
- Hey everyone, nice to be here.
My name is Sampada Chavan
and I'm part of the AI
platform product team
and the lead product manager
for AI Control Tower.
And Ofer.
- Hello everybody, my
name is Ofer Vaisler.
I'm part of the platform
product management team
and I lead the AI Control Tower.
So welcome to the session.
We're excited to have you.
Before we start, just have to
show this safe harbor slide.
You all know the drill.
Don't make purchasing decisions
based on future statements
and with that, let's start our session.
So we've prepared a great
presentation for you
about governance of AI
and about securing AI.
But before we jump into that,
I wanna talk about the ServiceNow platform
just a little bit.
So we built the ServiceNow platform
in order to automate work for people.
You all know that.
And we've been doing that
now for over 20 years.
So in fact, today our platform
powers billions and billions
of automations every month.
Flows, playbooks for many,
many thousands of customers
across all industries.
So automation is not really new to us.
In fact, it's part of who we are.
It's part of our identity.
Now we all know that the
landscape is changing
and AI is taking the world by storm.
And we think that this change
is going to be pretty significant.
I'm sure some of you, if
you're at least as old as me,
then you remember when
virtualization came out.
Everybody thought in the beginning
that this is about saving server costs.
Well, fast forward for today,
it turns out that it fueled
the entire revolution
into cloud computing,
enabling new products,
new services, new business models.
And we think that AI is
gonna be at least as big,
if not bigger than that.
And that's why we've built AI natively
into the ServiceNow platform,
making sure that it
continues to be the platform
for business transformation
into the AI era.
Now we think that the AI
revolution is gonna be so big
that over the next few years,
every workflow for every industry
is going to be reimagined with AI.
That's a pretty bold statement.
But we know that AI is
not a one-size-fits-all.
We know that in order to
build amazing AI experiences,
you have to pick the right model.
You have to pick the right data.
You have to pick the right infrastructure
that it will run on.
So we know that that's exactly why
we built the ServiceNow
platform in a flexible way
that allows you to do exactly that.
You pick the use case, and based on that,
you pick the right model for the use case.
You pick the right data for the use case.
And you pick the right cloud
that you want this use case to run on
so it runs most efficiently at scale.
So we all know how powerful AI
and how big is the potential, right?
It can help unlock so many
amazing business outcomes.
It can increase productivity.
It can accelerate time to market.
It can reduce costs.
But even more than that,
it's actually becoming
table stakes, right?
If you're not implementing AI,
then you're gonna stay behind.
You're not gonna be able to
stay ahead of your competition.
And that's why it's not surprising
that we're seeing many of our customers
now looking to move from
experimenting with AI
to operationalizing AI at scale.
But the potential is huge,
but with this potential,
there are also increasing risks, right?
If you played with AI and
you experimented with AI,
you know that having a
successful POC is one thing,
and scaling AI and getting
enterprise value out of it
is a different thing.
So AI obviously comes with
huge set of challenges.
It's an undeterministic
technology by nature, right?
So you cannot overlook things like bias,
hallucinations, or lack of transparency.
Also, there are increasing concerns
about risks and security
issues and data privacy,
especially as this technology
becomes more capable
and even more so, more autonomous.
So scaling AI is not just
a technology challenge,
but it's actually at least as
big as a governance challenge.
Now, as you start looking
into organizations
and how they're implementing AI
and who's involved in this process,
you tend to see two forces.
On the one hand, you have product owners
and business users who
want to prove value fast
and move as quickly as possible.
On the other hand, you have
risk teams and security teams
and compliance teams and legal teams.
They also want to move fast,
but they're thinking all the time
about all the new threats that are coming
if AI is gonna be used without
the appropriate guardrails.
So many companies are stuck
in this kind of phase of analysis
when they're looking to transition
between proof of concept to scaling AI.
And most of them do not have
the right governance process
and tools in place to enable
that scale with trust.
So in response, we are
seeing many organizations
that have either created or
are in the process of creating
AI centers of excellence.
Those centers of
excellence are responsible
for holistically managing and coordinating
and governing the implementation of AI
across the enterprise.
But just creating those organizations
is not gonna be enough.
What you really need is
a seamless collaboration
between all the stakeholders
that are involved
in the process of
building AI, deploying AI,
and addressing issues like risks
and compliance issues when they arise.
What's needed is a true way
to break down all the silos
and have everybody on one platform.
Everybody need to speak the same language,
everybody need to see the same data,
everybody need to get the same context
from a technology perspective
and from a business perspective
in order to understand
how those AI initiatives
are going to impact the business.
And that's exactly why we
built the AI Control Tower.
The AI Control Tower
provides an integrated
and holistic approach to
manage your AI at scale.
So you don't need to trade off
between moving fast and moving safe.
You can now do both.
So it streamlines all the life cycle of AI
from onboarding to change to offboarding,
and it connects all the dots
between your AI strategy,
your AI execution, your AI governance,
and the value that you're
generating from AI.
So all of that is built
also on top of our CMDB,
and that is a super important fact.
And let me now just touch
on each one of those pillars
so that you can understand a
little bit more the details,
and then we will go into a live demo
that will show you how it
all works in real life.
So let's start with the
underlying data model.
Here's the thing,
AI assets are just like
any technology assets.
They need to be discovered,
they need to be tracked,
they need to be governed,
just like any other server
or business application or network device
that you're already managing.
And that's why we built
ServiceNow Control Tower
on top of CMDB.
So the AI Control Tower
discovers all your AI footprint,
and not just agents, but also the models
that those agents are running on,
the data sets that those
agents are trained on,
the prompts that help define
those agents and what they do,
and this is how the AI Control Tower
provides a single system of record
for all your AI footprint on one platform.
And because it's integrated with CMDB,
it is also out-of-the-box coordinated
and tightly aligned with
your technology architecture,
your network architecture,
and your workflows.
Now, when you think about AI,
you always want to start
with your strategy.
You want to make sure
that all your AI efforts
are tightly aligned to
your business objective.
And that's why we integrated AICT
with our strategic portfolio
management solution
to give you exactly that visibility
and connection to your strategy.
So what you can do with AI Control Tower
is you can connect all
your business priorities
and business goals into
your AI initiatives
to make sure that your AI efforts
and your strategy are tightly aligned.
Now, with AI moving so fast,
it's critical that
execution will be flawless.
So with the AI Control Tower,
we've also packaged out-of-the-box
workflows and playbooks
that allows you to run all
the AI lifecycle seamlessly,
ensuring that nothing
falls between the cracks.
So for example, if a team
wants to onboard a new model,
that kicks off a new workflow
that goes to security teams,
to risk teams, to legal teams for review
to ensure that this model is not onboarded
and become operationalized
without the appropriate
reviews and sign-off.
Same for, let's say
you wanna make a change
to a model that is powering an agent,
or at some point you would also
want to retire some assets.
All of those playbooks
are packaged together
with the AI Control Tower,
ensuring that your execution is smooth
and everybody are on the same page.
Now also, when you
deploy a new application,
a new agent, a new model,
you wanna make sure you have
the right controls in place,
you wanna make sure that you stay
in compliance of regulations,
you wanna make sure that
you have auditability
and access to audit trails.
So AICT is integrated with our
market-leading IRM solution,
which allows you to
track your risk exposure.
It also comes with out-of-the-box
regulatory frameworks
like AI EU Act, so it maps your risks
into the right compliance framework
and regulation and it ensures
that your exposure is minimized.
Now at the end of the day,
the last pillar of the AI
Control Tower is value.
Everybody want to understand
what is the bottom line,
what return am I getting
on all those investments?
So with AI Control Tower,
you can see all kind of
value operational metrics
like productivity gains or ROI.
And because we know that
value is defined differently
for different use cases,
then we built a very
flexible value framework
that allows you to create
custom value templates
and associate them to the use cases
and measure value the way
you want to measure it.
So the result is AICT helps you unlock
all this potential of AI at scale,
move from proof of concept
to successful implementations
that actually produce real value at scale,
but better aligning with
your business goals,
streamlining your project
delivery, maintaining compliance,
and seeing the value
that you're generating.
And with that, I wanna hand it to Sampada
to show us a real live
demo of the product.
You can see how it all comes together.
- Thank you, Ofer.
All right, so let me
switch over to the view
that the AICOE sees.
So with AI Control Tower, we
talked about how the AICOE,
the governance team actually
helps connect the dot
across multiple cross-functional teams.
And what this AICOE gets to view
is the state of the AI in the enterprise.
So they have a view of all
of the different AI systems
which are available.
Where are they in their life cycle?
What types of AI do you have?
So within the AI inventory,
we can track AI agents,
your generative use cases,
even the classical AIML use cases
where you were fine-tuning models for,
let's say, prediction or
classification type of use cases.
The data model handles that.
You also have a view into
what is the overall risk classification
for those AI systems.
Where are you sourcing them from?
So it could be ServiceNow AI,
AI that is on your AWS instances.
It could be AI that is embedded
in other software applications,
bringing those all in.
And then looking at
overall where do you stand
in terms of the compliance,
in terms of your standards, regulations,
or even your own internal
governance policies.
You can also track the productivity.
Value is very important.
You would want to understand
how AI is being used,
what value it is deriving,
and you would have the ability
to measure that as well.
So once you have this overview
of AI in the enterprise,
you can then start digging deeper
into each of the aspects of it.
When I look at AI strategy,
I am able to look at
what are my overall strategic priorities,
what are the targets that
are associated with it,
and how am I tracking towards those,
those particular goals as well.
I could potentially also
look at planned costs
if I have access to it,
and prioritize my AI work.
So again, ensuring that the AI
that is getting built and deployed
aligns with your overall AI strategy
that you want to implement
in your organization.
In AI asset inventory,
you are going to get a little bit deeper
into what type of AI
artifacts are available.
So you have your AI
systems, the AI models,
prompt templates, even data sets
that you could be using for evaluations.
If you're fine-tuning and
training your own models,
you could capture those data
set information as well.
And then additional information
on how those assets are
spread across the board.
Next up with value,
this is where you are
going to start looking at
what is the overall value
that AI in the organization is driving,
where does usage look like,
and potentially a scoreboard
of what are your most used systems,
what are the most valuable systems.
You get a view and an
insight into that as well.
Next up with risk and compliance,
this is going the next level of detail
into risk status and classification
of individual assets.
So be it AI systems,
different models, data sets,
it all comes together
along with the compliance
of where we are in terms
of the particular standards
or regulations that you're looking at,
as well as your own internal policies.
Now how does all of this
information come together?
So it starts off with ways
of getting the data into the inventory.
You could have a standard intake process
where as a user I can go in and say that,
"Hey, I want to build this use case out,"
or, "I want to use this
model in my system."
Another way to look at it is also
where we provide discovery capabilities.
So by directly connecting to AWS Bedrock,
we are able to bring in agents
and their associated information
into this inventory as well.
Now let's talk about an
example of such an agent.
I'm gonna pull that up.
Here we talk about this
autonomous recruiting agent
which is being used or built
and deployed on AWS Bedrock.
We are able to bring the information
or the metadata about that
agent, but it's not just that.
Along with it, we are
also able to bring in
what are the related
assets or artifacts to it,
because that is what is going
to give you the full picture
of how an agent is going to be designed
and then deployed and
then used in the system
or in your enterprise.
So you have a view into what
are the different other agents
that this particular
agent would be calling,
what are the tools this
particular agent has access to,
what are the models that this
particular agent is using,
and so on and so forth.
And then once you have
all of this information,
you will want to ensure that
you are onboarding this agent
into your enterprise.
So that's where playbooks
come into play, into picture,
wherein as a playbook, I
can set up different tasks
of bringing those
cross-functional teams together
to run either an impact assessment
to understand how is this
agent going to be used?
How does it handle fairness and bias?
Is there going to be a
human oversight present?
And based on that, you can also look at,
does legal need to wane?
Is there data security
and privacy concerns
that we need to look at?
Kind of bringing all of
that information together
will then help you understand
what is the risk associated
with that particular asset.
So once you run through that,
you run through those
different assessments,
you can then identify what
are the risks associated
with this particular agent
to mitigate those risks,
what type of controls do I need to handle?
And then as you move this
agent through its lifecycle
of assessing, approving
it to be built and tested,
you can then start looking at validating
whether those controls are present,
do you have the right set
of guardrails available?
And also at point in time,
look at how do you measure value of that?
And those are all tasks
that would be associated
or provided to the specific users,
bringing those teams together.
An example of how do you measure value
is going to be looking at
a formula that we look at,
like once this agent is deployed,
we would want to then
look at how many times
is this agent going to be used?
And this is where the data will come in
from those CloudWatch integrations
that I just showed you.
So we look at how many
times this particular agent
is going to run, and
then making an assumption
in this particular case that
every time this agent runs,
we are saving about 10
minutes of an end user time,
so that becomes our productivity metric.
And assuming an accuracy of 85%
is also the way we would capture
the value for this agent.
Now this is constants,
but you could completely
bring in additional data
streams into the platform
to have indicators available
to run this particular formula.
So now imagine this is
everything that we are doing
for one single agent.
When we start doing this over
multiple different AI systems,
the models, that is
where we start bringing
all of that together into
this AI control tower view
that we first started off with.
So I focused a little
bit on the inventory,
the risk and compliance, and
the lifecycle of that asset.
Amanda is now going to talk about
the data security and privacy aspects.
- Great, thank you Sampada.
So Sampada just gave us a fantastic demo
of AI control tower, and also talked about
how that helps you
manage your AI lifecycle,
govern your AI, and manage the strategy
and understand the value of your AI.
I'm going to talk about another aspect,
which is the security of your AI.
And we're really in a completely
new era of cyber security.
I've been in cyber security over 20 years,
and this year, the pace
of change has just been,
I would say, at least 3x any
other year, if not higher.
And we've really moved from
security being on computers
or individual devices, to cloud security,
which was a massive shift,
and now to AI security,
which is another really seismic shift.
And all of the existing
challenges that we had in,
or that we still have in
the cloud security era,
in terms of things like data
breaches, privacy leaks,
adversarial attacks,
whether from nation states
or malicious actors who
are trying to make money,
all of these challenges still exist,
but now we have new
challenges to worry about.
Thinking about what AI agents can access,
thinking about MCP and agent-to-agent,
being concerned about model
poisoning and prompt injections.
So, with that in mind,
these are some of the key considerations
that you need to think about
when you're considering
deploying AI agents.
The first pillar really is the
identity and access controls.
We consider that AI agents
are a new type of identity,
somewhere between humans,
because they're kind of like
anthropomorphized humans,
and machines, because
they're kind of like code.
But just like humans, we
are going to need to ensure
that they adhere to the
standard security principle
of least privilege.
They should only have enough
access to do their job,
and not more than that.
I'm also very excited
that ServiceNow today
announced the intent to acquire VASA,
a modern identity security company,
which I believe is really going to enhance
the ServiceNow AI agent trust story,
because today we are well-known
as a system of record for IT assets.
We are also very well-known
as a system of action
across many different types of use cases,
and now we will be a system of
record for identity as well.
Second pillar that you need to
think about is data security,
and this is ever more
important in the AI era,
where we all know that
AI needs tons of data
to be able to operate efficiently,
but it's more important than ever
to know where your sensitive data is,
and ensure that that data is protected.
So those first two pillars
are really the hard boundaries
that are essential for the
foundations of secure AI.
The next pillar is the guardrails.
So ServiceNow is actually,
we have a model agnostic strategy,
so we work with all
the major hyperscalers,
including obviously AWS,
and all of these LLMs have,
all the LLM providers have
guardrails built into them.
On ServiceNow, we have our
own guardrails as well,
called ServiceNow, or
called Now Assist Guardian,
which ensures that the,
it's monitoring for offensive content,
detecting prompt injections,
and also detecting personally
identifiable information.
Finally, monitoring is an essential part
of any security strategy,
ensuring that you know what's going on,
and ensuring that you have an audit trail
in case something does go wrong.
So let's just talk a little
bit more about identity
and how this impacts security.
So again, I talked a little bit about
how security was very localized.
In the cloud era, identity
really became the new perimeter.
But what we're seeing in the AI era
is the boundaries between
internal and external IT
are starting to blur more and more,
because the vision really that we have
is that AI agents will
be acting on our behalf
and working across different platforms
to be able to carry out
autonomous actions on our behalf.
So this means there is just going to be
an absolute explosion
in non-human identities.
And that explosion has even
really already started.
In fact, there was a report by Imperva,
now part of Thales this year,
that said 51% of internet
traffic is automated.
So as AI agents become more perfect,
this is only going to get even bigger.
And we're seeing an evolution
still in the standards.
We have things like MCP, agent-to-agent,
that do require OAuth, but it
doesn't really go deep enough.
And I think we're going to need to see,
in particular, more standards evolving
around cross-platform authorization
or cross-platform access controls.
Today, the problem that
identity providers really solve
is cross-platform authentication.
So another reason why I'm
super excited about ServiceNow,
announcing the intent to purchase VESA.
So we will see what happens there.
But even today, we have a great view
to help you with your AI
with AI Control Tower.
And AI Control Tower helps you
with the security of
AI agents and AI assets
by providing you visibility into access,
ensuring that you have the trust
that your AI assets have
the right level of access,
showing privacy violations,
ensuring that any sensitive data,
especially personally
identifiable information,
is either redacted or
detected as appropriate,
and giving you visibility
into the security
through either guardrail detections
or providing that observability chain.
And with that, I'm gonna
have Sampada come back up,
and we're going to show another
demo of AI Control Tower.
So I just wanna show a couple of use cases
that AI Control Tower can help with,
showing when AI agents
have privileged access,
which can indicate potentially more risk,
showing dormant agent, sorry,
identifying dormant agents,
potentially agents that
are ready for retirement,
they don't need that access anymore,
showing streamlined access visibility.
We're also showing already
AI scoring, security scoring,
with plans to enhance that in our,
very soon coming up in
our January release,
we're gonna be adding the
new AI VSS scoring mechanism,
as well as not just highlighting issues,
but showing automated issue resolution.
So with that, I will pass
to Sampada again, thank you.
- Thank you, Amanda.
All right, so let's talk about
the security and privacy tab.
As Amanda mentioned, for
someone to truly trust
and have that confidence in AI,
securing data, having
that confidence in privacy
is very important.
And with AI Control Tower,
you are able to manage that
data security and privacy
for all of your AI systems,
be it ServiceNow or with AWS,
those are the agents
that we are discovering.
What you will see here is that
the first and foremost important thing
is to have that
transparency and visibility
of what data do your
agents have access to.
And you kind of do that
through your access maps.
So as you go to an access map,
I can bring up a particular agent,
I can look at what are the different tools
that agent is leveraging.
Let's take this as an example.
You have access to that, you
can then get information about
the particular type of that
tool, where it is running,
what data it would be getting access to.
And that helps in understanding
and having that truly
transparency and visibility
into how your agents run.
The next step is, how
are these agents running?
Are they running in a supervised fashion
or are they autonomous?
And having that visibility
into what are your autonomous
agents is extremely important,
because knowing that,
you are able to then set
what are the right set of guardrails
that you would want to ensure
that the agents run within.
Now digging a little bit
deeper, once your agents run,
you also would want to understand
how are these agents running,
with what access levels
are they running with.
Any agents that are running
with an admin access
would be considered privileged agents,
and you get a visibility
into how many of your overall
agents in your ecosystem
are running with that higher access.
On the other side, you
would also want to know
which agents are not being used,
because they become open doors
for threats and vulnerabilities.
So with AI Control Tower, you
will be able to also get to
how many agents are dormant.
The next step is the guardrails
that Amanda was talking about.
With that, we would be
able to bring in guardrails
around things around what
is offensive content.
With Guardian, you can identify
different types of offensive content
in terms of either toxic content
or inappropriate content.
You could flag that,
you know how your agents are performing.
The other piece that is
also equally important
is the sensitive data.
So you would want to understand
are your agents processing
or handling sensitive data,
which could be PII.
In this example, of all the
data that we have collected,
we have not identified it.
But again, having visibility into that
becomes extremely important.
And then, if there is
sensitive data detected,
you would also want to have anonymized.
We would then capture
that information as well.
All of this information is great,
but you really want to
make this actionable.
So what we then offer is insights.
So as your insights run,
and this is live, so let's
see how it comes across.
So with that, you can see
where are things that are working well,
what are the areas that need attention,
and anything that is
particularly actionable,
we would be able to drive that as well.
So by bringing together the inventory,
the governance and the
lifecycle that we talked about,
and then completing it up
with the security and privacy,
with AI Control Tower,
you can actually have your full oversight
and governance for AI in the enterprise.
Now, Amanda's going to
talk a little bit more
about how we get to the sensitive data
and managing that as well.
- Okay, great, thank you.
So AI Control Tower is all
about governing and securing
and managing AI across the enterprise.
But what about when you're building AI
specifically on the ServiceNow platform?
So we truly believe that
security is absolutely essential,
just as it was in the cloud era.
It's even more essential in the AI era
to be able to trust the platform
that you're running your AI on.
That's why at ServiceNow,
we have invested in multiple
layers of platform security
to give our customers the right controls
of the security and privacy of their data
to be able to bring
that data to ServiceNow.
So things like, I talked a lot already
about identity and access controls,
but also things like Security Center
to give you visibility into the posture,
the security posture of
your ServiceNow deployment.
Then for customers that need even more
and really want to make sure
that their data is secure,
we have ServiceNow Vault.
So let me talk a little
bit more about that
and why it's super important.
So a lot of people think about ServiceNow
as our roots IT service management,
but of course we've evolved a lot
since then being a Fortune 500 company,
serving multiple different
kinds of use cases
out of the box like CRM,
like security operations,
vulnerability management,
employee workflows,
finance and supply chain, like
you name the C-suite leader
and we pretty much have a
product for them out of the box.
Not only that, but the
power of ServiceNow platform
is its customizability.
So you can really fulfill
almost any kind of use case you want.
In fact, I had one of
the top four US banks
tell me recently, I love
the ServiceNow platform
because I can achieve in a few clicks
what my colleagues can only dream about.
They're talking in weeks or months
to achieve certain use cases.
But of course, with all of these use cases
comes more and more
types of sensitive data.
So it's very important
to be able to ensure
that you have the right visibility
and control over this data.
That's why we created ServiceNow Vault,
which is a unified console
to help you know your data,
protect your data and monitor your data.
And this is again, very important
because ServiceNow is in this,
I think very strong position in the AI era
of bringing together the
data that we already have,
now the AI and the workflows
to truly be able to automate
work across the enterprise.
And of course, not only are
we helping to secure AI,
but we're using AI to
help make security easier.
These are the products
that are included in Vault.
I won't go into too much of this
'cause I'm gonna show you in a demo,
but data privacy
essentially helps you find
not just personally
identifiable information,
but really any type of sensitive data.
Multiple layers of
encryption can be applied
either at volume or at the field level.
We can apply granular access policies.
We have near real-time export of log data
via Kafka Stream to your security,
log monitoring tool, your SIMs,
or whatever your log analytics
platform of choice is.
And we provide code signing to ensure code
that is being deployed
out to your IT assets
in your network is secure
and untampered with.
So let's take a look.
So here I am in a ServiceNow instance.
I'm going to start at the Vault console.
Now, we already have a good understanding
of the out-of-the-box applications,
so we are able to, we
know that this instance
has a couple of pre-built ServiceNow apps,
so I'm gonna get started.
And here I can see that
based on our knowledge
of the data model, we have
suggested data classifications.
Now, of course, as a customer,
you can review these data classifications
and make sure they adhere
to your company policies
and your local regulatory requirements,
adapt them if needed,
but providing you're good
with these classifications,
you simply need to check agree
and apply recommended classes.
So very simply, within a few clicks,
you're able to classify the
data of an entire application.
So, of course, we're not just finding data
via data templates, we're also using our,
we have pattern-based matching,
we have out-of-the-box templates,
and we also use AI to detect
personally identifiable information.
So once you have found the sensitive data,
then you have various different ways
that you can protect this data.
So one of the ways is anonymization.
It could be that, hey, this is
something like a credit card
or a social security number
that I just don't want
in the environment at all,
and I'm going to redact it,
or it could be that you're
cloning all of this data
to a lower-production environment,
and you want it all anonymized.
You want the developers that are working
in those lower-production environments
to have a very real-world-like environment
in terms of the shape
and size of the data,
but you don't want them to
see the actual sensitive data.
So that's a good use
case for anonymization.
You can encrypt.
This is a good compensating
access control,
and it also ensures an
extra layer of security
against insider threat access
against the cloud service
provider-privileged access users.
And then the third type of
protection that you can apply
is zero-trust access.
So these are above and beyond.
These are like dynamic access policies
that you can apply to
specific sensitive data
to when the risk, you can,
I'll show you an example,
but let's write a policy here.
So I'm going to create a
policy for confidential data.
I'm typing very fast. (laughs)
And I'm going to apply this
to all of our confidential
data for CSM case management.
And the policy that
I'm going to apply here
is that I'm going to enforce
multi-factor authentication.
Because this is highly confidential data,
I want to make sure that the user
really is who they say they are
when they're accessing this data.
But a couple of other types of policies
that you could choose to apply are
if the user's in a specific,
or in or out of a specific
geographic region,
in or out of a specific IP range,
we can also use risk factors
from the single sign-on,
so from the likes of Okta,
for example, as a factor.
So you can dynamically
change a person's access
based on their risk profile,
either at the time of logging in
or using continuous authentication.
So with this, I can see, for
this table of classified data,
what protections have been applied
and what's still available to me.
So now I can see that the
zero-trust access policies
have been applied to this table.
And just like that, again,
within a few clicks,
I have the ability to
find my sensitive data
and ensure that it's protected.
Now, we're not only detecting
data that's written in tables,
we're also doing this with real-time data.
So whether it's in Now
Assist, our AI-powered chat,
or email, for example,
you can also detect data in real-time.
So with this, I'm able to, again,
very quickly find and protect the data.
But that's not all.
As I said, we're also using AI
to make it easier to protect the data.
So I can chat with Now Assist and say,
can you write me a new filter to detect,
for example, a zip code?
And it will choose, generate
custom data pattern,
and it will help generate
that regular expression for me
in case I don't know how to
write regular expressions.
They're not that hard,
but not everybody knows how to write them.
And it will also test it for me.
And I can just say, looks
good, and I can apply that.
So now, I can use that both for, again,
written data or real-time data detection.
So that's how the Vault
console helps you find,
protect, and monitor your sensitive data.
And this helps you ensure
that data in the ServiceNow platform
is kept secure and private,
is aligning with regulatory compliance,
and really reducing your risk,
and enabling you to
bring more sensitive data
to the ServiceNow Cloud.
And really, this emphasizes that
with AI Control Tower and
with ServiceNow Vault,
you have security, privacy,
and access controls
really baked in and not bolted on.
And the reason why this
is ever more important
is because, again, those boundaries
between internal and external
IT are starting to blur.
With ServiceNow Workflow Data Fabric
that is connected to the AWS data lakes,
we're operating on the data
as if it's in ServiceNow.
So it's, again, super
important to be able to ensure
that you are able to monitor
the access of AI agents,
be able to detect sensitive data,
be able to do this for external AI,
and to have those security policy
enforcements and guardrails.
Thank you, hope you
have a great conference.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)